here it is the brand new iPhone 15 pro
and pro Max
joke that it's the same the same phone
as last year you'd be wrong especially
for photographers and videographers it
is so hard to even call this a phone
with the introduction of USBC for fast
data transfer the new 5x telephoto and
prores log it just so happens that my
camera can make phone calls
[Music]
[Applause]
the camera of course is where the new
iPhone 15 Pro shines but also this new
titanium finish that comes in natural
black white and blue titanium I've got
the new natural color right here and
also the blue and they are just so
stunning like the way that they reflect
the light so beautiful the thing that is
also really surprising is how light they
are compared to the previous version
it's only a slight weight difference but
with these new rounded edges it has an
all new feel to it now if you have an
Apple Watch Ultra this new natural
titanium is a perfect match another huge
design change is it now finally has USBC
the Pro Models will support up to USBC
speeds that are 20 times faster than the
regular iPhone 15. this is because of
the all-new a17 Pro trip for enhanced
performance so they've now made an
action button on the iPhone 15 pros this
used to be where the silent switch was
but now you can actually customize this
button to do basically whatever you want
you can still have it silence your
iPhone if you choose to but you can
select from Focus modes camera options
flashlights voice memo magnifier you can
create custom shortcuts accessibility or
you can have it do nothing which is kind
of pointless I don't know why you would
even select that I have mine set up to
access the camera since that's pretty
much what I use my phone for you can
even use the action button as a shutter
button the display has slightly thinner
borders Dynamic island is back and
promotion on the pros give you a super
smooth animation you can choose from the
6.1 inch or the 6.7 inch sizes but the
max version is the only camera that has
the 5x Zoom now speaking of 5x Zoom this
new tech in the telephoto is called
tetraprism and this uses a series of
mirrors to reflect and magnify to keep
the camera lens much smaller that's one
of the things we always joke about each
year the camera bumps get larger and
larger so using this Tetra prism this
allows for you to keep the camera bumps
much smaller and they don't have to be
increased in size but yet we still get
that 5x magnification
so here on Catalina there's this old
casino and it's now turned into a museum
and a dive shop and we're up here on the
hill and I'm going to show you guys a
little demo of the zoom that we have on
the new 15 Pro Max only it'll go up to
5x but the main camera now also can act
as three lenses a 24 a 28 and a 35
millimeter so when you click through on
the 1X you'll be able to see those
change just like this my favorite demo
though is going from the wide angle all
the way into the 5x this really shows
you the perspective that you're able to
get this is equivalent to 120 millimeter
focal length pretty far out dude
[Music]
I took the new phones to Catalina to
test them out diving
[Music]
they are water and dust resistant up to
six meters for 30 minutes but I use this
new oceanic plus housing which will let
you turn your phone into a dive computer
and also capture videos and photos up to
196 feet now I have a full review on
this housing in another video but it is
so incredible now most of this video
footage that you're seeing here I shot
in 4k 60 because this lets me slow down
the footage in post if I see a fast
fishy or if I'm floating around too fast
and a current Oceanic plus is the same
app that was launched last year with the
Apple watch Ultra to let you turn your
Apple watch into a dive computer so it
is so cool that you can now do this with
your iPhone
[Music]
without taking photos and videos all
around Catalina my favorite thing we
shot though was this Wes Anderson
stealth Tick Tock meme video using the
prores log and I'm so happy with how it
turned out behind the scenes of our Wes
Anderson Tick Tock so vertical content
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
shooting in log is really cool because
it gives you so much more flexibility in
editing with color and it also can save
some highlights if it's a super bright
day so let's test them out and see what
we got
everybody
[Music]
I also didn't realize that you can shoot
in prores on the front-facing camera so
right now shooting prores front-facing
camera now the thing with prores though
is it is going to increase your file
sizes which is one of the reasons why
this feature is specifically on the pros
now if I want to shoot in 4k 60 this is
where a little notification pops up and
it says prores not supported but it will
be supported when recording to external
storage now I'm going to try recording
externally to this little OWC drive this
is one terabyte so we're going to switch
this into the prores log and to 60
frames a second plug it in and it's time
to record
[Music]
I was also super impressed with how well
the shop videos at night here's a demo
of a shot that was shot in log and here
is one that's just regular and you can
kind of see here in the lights how it
saved a little more detail and it's less
blown out around the lights night mode
also got a little boost as well so
here's a few photos that took handheld
on the 15. you can see all of the detail
here especially in the 5x Zoom is pretty
impressive this is a difficult shot
because there's like a lot of like
there's also not a lot of light
foreign
[Music]
15 Pro camera system because it is newer
and it is the latest and the greatest
and is the best iPhone that Apple has
ever made I like to kind of test them
out in comparison to the previous
version let's see if we can tell the
difference
[Music]
we're gonna get ice cream
this is all you properly do an iPhone
review
[Music]
there's a few new Pro options now that
you can quickly access here in the top
menu now you do need to first turn these
on in the settings now when you're in
the camera you can press to hold and
quickly switch between the options as
needed I shot most of my photos just in
normal mode and in raw Max the hype mode
will give you a higher resolution image
at a much smaller file size but since I
have the one terabyte phone I just shot
in the Pro max resolution for most of my
photos when I wasn't shooting in the
normal it's golf cart time this is my
favorite part about Catalina is running
a golf cart and going and exploring the
island
[Music]
now action mode isn't something new but
it's still so impressive you can also
see in this demo here that we're on a
super bouncy golf cart and it's able to
really stabilize that footage so much
better and it made it super smooth these
were also shot in logs so here's what it
looks like before the color and here's
what it looks like after I'm not gonna
lie I don't really shoot that much in
cinematic mode normally but when I do
I'm always so impressed with how great
it looks so now cinematic mode supports
digital Zoom from 1X to 3x so you can
tap one or two and then you can use the
scroll wheel to go all the way up to
three now in regular video you can do
this as well but all the way up to 15.
something else I noticed is how smooth
the zoom is so when you're using the
scroll wheel you can really fine tune
your zoom and get as close or as far
away from your subject as you like
I love being able to go in and
egg mode so when you're in here as you
tap on something on the screen as you're
playing the video it'll change the focus
from whichever point of interest that
you want it to focus on so as you'll see
here I've tapped on my face and then
I've tapped back here on the background
and now it's focusing not on me it's
focusing more in the background and as
you continue through on this timeline
this gives you the ability to reshoot
what you already shot it's also great
because if you do bring a cinematic clip
into Final Cut you can do the same
action and change the focal point there
as well
foreign
obviously for me testing out photos and
video is my favorite thing but a few of
the other updates is the new wireless
tech with the new 2nd gen Ultra wideband
chip this enables Precision finding for
friends now this is of course only if
your friend wants to be found but when
you turn this on it'll give you precise
turn-by-turn directions of getting to
your friend much like when you're trying
to find your airpods so I love gaming
and they are really turning this phone
into a console level gaming device with
the new A7 Pro chip this is giving
performance improvements for games like
mesh shading and Hardware accelerated
Ray tracing I also really like that I
can charge my airpods or Apple watch
using the charge port and since it's
USBC this is a great time to pick
yourself up a nice pink iJustine USBC
cable to go with it pink
ijustinecables.com Shameless plug
roadside assistance has also been added
to the satellite emergency offering
using AAA which I actually have AAA so
hyped about that this is pretty great if
you get a flat tire or you break down
and you need help I've definitely been
there so it is nice to know that you can
use the satellite for more than just a
super emergency situation so all in all
I have been loving the new phone and of
course if you do already have an iPhone
14 pro device this isn't going to be
like some huge massive overhaul
physically but if you are super into
video the new zoom and the ability to
shoot in log is so awesome I love the
new titanium finish and how light it is
it just feels so nice in your hand it's
fast with all the added iOS 17 features
it definitely does feel like a really
great upgrade I have a bunch of other
Apple videos here if you want to check
them out after this thank you guys for
watching and let me know what your
favorite color iPhone is this season